so what was it like working with Stanley
Kramer I was known as a great dramatic
director and you how many films that
you've done at this point I don't know
quite a few but I would like to say that
he gave me no direction I was in that
tower in the tower I would like to tell
a story about being and the traffic
controller with Paul Ford was a main
traffic controller and this is my my
memory of it my memory was fear
absolutely true traffic controller Paul
Ford is on the microphone and he's
screaming at the Buddy Hackett and
they're piloting a plane with a dead
pilot and they're coming toward the
tower piloting the plane was a guy named
Paul Mantz one of the great stunt pilots
in the world Paul Ford goes out onto the
parapet outside the tower and is trying
to wave at the plane he falls off the
tower and is hanging by a thread by his
cord and he's hanging there so it's up
to me to come out and continue to try to
get control of the plane this is true
now now you're you're me Paul Paul Mantz
is coming at me and I'm waving the plane
away like this wave wave is sticking up
and a plane is coming at me this is the
plane coming at my head like this coming
right at my head and I'm waving it away
and I literally literally Paul Mantz and
I could see it it might be a 300 feet
away and I'm waving like and he's coming
right at me and it's the last second he
does what all great stunt pilots - by
the way I'm waving and I actually
touched the plane because what what
happened as that last second he turned
the plane this way and sped past my head
like coming this way and all of a sudden
this and I'm going I touched the plane
well the biggest laugh in the [ __ ] and
the whole show you'll watch the show
today you'll get big laughs the biggest
laugh in the whole picture has a laugh I
got that is not on screen what happened
there were there were 200 people at the
extras below us in the crowd all
screaming and yelling and there 200 them
Rimmer and they're screaming and yelling
now the big joke in show business is
that when you when you have a take that
is not on your face it's doing other
words when an actor wants a real good
close-up there's a far shot and the joke
of the actor always says you know after
the shot is over make up make up meaning
why don't you get it closer I'm not
gonna happen so make up because you
couldn't see me so that I know the the
camera was way down at the bottom taking
the whole shot I knew they couldn't
possibly see me it was just a figure
waving so I yelled out at the end after
they say cut I yelled out underwear
biggest laugh in the whole picture